so let me start first by
uh highlighting some of the things that
probably many of us
already know for example cancer
which is one of the leading causes of
morbidity and mortality worldwide
is much more prevalent in areas of the
western world
that has a growing and older population
and so if you think about that trend of
the population becoming older
and having additional comorbidities
it is clear that to address this
effectively
the same standard measures that are
working for everyone
are not going to work for any particular
individual
in a very precise and effective way
and so it's very important for us to
recognize this trend
and to understand what are some of the
ways that we could effectively address
this growing problem
that is going to require much much more
investments
in new technologies to address these
pressing needs
for example when we think about cancer
we need to understand
what are the drivers of cancer
progression
what are the risks associated with
developing cancer
and therefore develop screening and
early diagnostic
tools to develop what are
to develop an understanding of what are
the markers of cancer risk and
progression
and so in that kind of approach
what we're really seeking to understand
is how can we detect these
molecular signatures that are very
specific and unique to each individual
and be able to recognize that small
piece of
data that signal out of noisy
huge data sets that are generated every
day for millions
of patients around the world and what
that
has to do with are new technologies that
allow us to look directly into the dna
understand the genes and rna
transcription
and look at the sequences of individual
cells
and tissues as this disease
develops over time and so what we're
looking at
is really a collection of complex data
sets that include
patient-derived cell lines
patient-derived xenograft models or
animal models
with human tumors in them so the cell
lines and the
patient-derived xenograph models are
some examples of how we can study the
basic biology
behind this disease but also we can
incorporate the clinical trials
and some of the big data collected from
real patients
where we can find some signature
information
and start to ask questions and
eventually what we're seeing as a result
of that
is more precise and targeted therapy
for many diseases including cancer
therapy
and a lot of these are actually changing
our ability
to treat people more effectively based
on these molecular signatures combining
our understanding of
drug metabolism with our understanding
with genetic predisposition
and with an appreciation of disease
progression or the basic biology behind
how this disease goes from non-malignant
to more and more malignant and invasive
and eventually metastatic cancers
that ultimately lead to death and so
this appreciation
of data really is central
to our ability to be able to provide
more effective
and precise treatment of patients now
unfortunately what that
brings us to are some big challenges
with data that is very diverse
very uh different because it was
generated by
thousands of labs around the world
different hands
different methods and approaches it was
generated from many different types of
people we don't know all the information
about those people
so really it's a problem of big data and
this problem of big data
is a different type of a challenge than
what clinicians
and biologists are used to so
biologists coming from a life science
background are used to
clean data experimental data data that
had a design
data that had very specific parameters
included in how the data was generated
and therefore you can test your
hypothesis
by looking at the signal in that data
and for clinicians i think it's even
much more challenging than that because
what they're used to be
dealing with is data that is not high
throughput it is
data that is obtained from lab reports
those lab reports come with a medical
history with a medical background
and are contextualized by medical
knowledge
that that individual or that location
really has
and so as opposed to that when we come
to this
challenge of big data in the clinical
application
we need to appreciate some things that
are coming really from the research side
as well as understand the context
for many different patients that we
could potentially not ever
interact with but they're really
repositories of raw data
that we can mine and extract some
meaningful signatures from
and potentially that could help us
answer some important questions about
the patients that we interact with
and so at the baseline of this i think
is
one of these technologies and this
technology is called next generation
sequencing
and i think that for many of you
probably you've heard a lot about
genomic data you've probably heard about
the applications of genomic
medicine in a variety of different
diseases but i think what is important
is for everyone to have
that skill set and have that expertise
in being able to
look at the data understand its quality
be able to find specific signal and then
to also lead to biological or even
clinical interpretation of that signal
and that's really what this program is
going to be about
so we're going to introduce you to a
number of different ways to study this
kind of data
analyze sample projects that we've
prepared and curated for you to
understand the specific questions
and the applications of that data set
and then
introduce you to some of the
methodologies that will be useful for
you to
practically work with such data sets
understanding
genomic variants understanding gene
expression
and the variation in gene expression
based on differential gene expression
looking at the annotation and
interpretation of how these
differentially expressed genes could be
combined
into specific biological pathways and
how can we really understand the
biological pathways
in the context of a particular disease
or a biomedical question and so one of
the repositories that we will turn to
is what's called the cancer genome atlas
or tcga
now tcga is a very important
uh repository of thousands of samples
collected from
patients that are that have many
different types of cancer so coming from
different tissue and and
buying sites and what it provides us is
some kind of an appreciation for
multi-omics data
and its role in understanding the
disease stratification so how is disease
uh variable between different patients
patient stratification how different
patients
are represented in this data set they
come from different ethnic backgrounds
different age groups different
sexes genders and how can we
use this data to understand the disease
in a much more precise way so this is
a really unique repository that actually
anyone can gain
access to and start downloading that
data to be able to ask
research questions finding associations
between
treatments between risks between
different types of omics data and so
what we will address in this program
is how to integrate such data to be able
to find
patterns that are relevant to
different types of cancers we'll also
take a look
at some of the algorithmic approaches
that allow us to apply
machine learning to extract
signal from data sets that were
generated in a high throughput way
and so one unique aspect of high
throughput
high throughput experiments is that the
data has been generated
in an automated way and we can generate
such data
from cell lines based on for example
response to treatment
so ultimately the goal there is not to
understand the molecular mechanisms
behind
efficacy of drug treatment for example
but it's really to find associations to
understand
some signal some kind of biomarker of
efficacy and that kind of information
can then help us
assign better treatments to patients not
by
understanding and studying each patient
individually
but actually running some algorithms
that could bring out that information in
front of the
in front of the person who is delivering
the treatment
and guiding them in their decision
making so there we will take a look at
how
actually both of these are integrated so
we'll take a look at
animal model experiments cell line
experiments and then compare them
to the variability in patients looking
at
research articles that describe the data
sets
and trying to extract signal that is
aligned between
cell lines animal models and ultimately
addresses the challenges
with individual patients now in addition
to
cancer many other diseases are going to
be
on everyone's mind obviously we live in
an
era of a pandemic and so it's important
to appreciate
the role that viruses play
not only in the pandemic that we're
experiencing right now
but also in many other conditions so a
lot of times we think of infectious
diseases like source growth ii
as a virus that is causing a pandemic
but surprisingly many different viruses
are involved in a variety of diseases
for example
bar virus is involved in many cancers
hepatitis can lead to liver cancer
so there's many diseases including
neurological diseases that could be
associated with either the direct
effect of the infection or inflammation
that is caused by chronic infection and
so we'll take a look at
how other types of diseases could also
be studied
using technologies like next generation
sequencing to understand
the disease itself the immunology or the
host response to that disease
and the variability in disease
manifestation in many different types of
patients
because of what is actually going on in
different tissues
and cells that we look at through the
lens of data
and so that's why i think that
bioinformatics
is really central to our ability to
improve
medicine and improve treatment that is
more effective
less toxic and guided by our
understanding of these molecular
signatures
and so to develop bioinformatics skills
you need to have some sense of the
biology
computer science and the statistical
methods that are used to analyze such
data
and so we hope that as a result of this
program what you will be able to gain
is an understanding of a variety of
bioinformatics algorithms and software
to appreciate the different databases of
data
that includes genomic data from cancer
studies infectious disease studies and
other diseases
you will appreciate the analytical
techniques
and approaches that are needed to
analyze data and you will be exposed to
a variety of data science skills that if
you are interested in you can pursue
further
in other types of training to develop a
practical skill set that is needed
for the age of big data and so as an
example
we have here a few omics data and
infectious disease research that i think
will also cover
in many of the sessions that we'll
discuss that will include
an overview of viral genomics and
evolution
immune response biomarkers as well as an
overview of microbiome and its role
in infection now obviously a lot of what
i'm saying
seems like too much to cover in a single
program and so that's why
what our team has done is collected a
number of program resources
that we're going to be making available
to all of the program participants
to make this a more streamlined and
effective use of your valuable time
so we will not only cover these live
sessions like we're doing today
we're also going to provide you access
to our training materials
fast big data analysis tools that you
can run
via a visual graphic user interface
curated project data set so you don't
have to spend all of your time
finding data but you will be given some
data sets that you can quickly go
through to understand
the point and the connection between the
analysis and the biological
relevance as well as these interactive
sessions
that will be guided by mentors that i
will introduce in just a couple more
minutes
but before i do that i want to introduce
you i know that some of you are probably
already familiar with this
but i'm going to briefly speak about our
big data analysis platform
that allows anyone to quickly go through
some of the
important methods in bioinformatics and
try them out on different types of
projects
so we will in a second go into
how to register and how to create an
account and
once you do we will take a look at this
big data analysis platform
so that you can understand that you can
both learn and then
use this platform for actual research
projects that you might have
and so here you will find a variety of
different types of omics data that you
can analyze
you can run demo pipelines to understand
the logic behind
some of the different analyses that we
will use you will also see
how you can share your analysis with
someone else
so that someone like a mentor can
provide you with technical information
about what went wrong in your analysis
and it also includes user-friendly tools
to apply
data mining and annotation of biological
information so that you can get quick
insights about the data sets you're
analyzing
so to really see how all of this works
let's go to learn.omixlogic.com
and let's start by creating an account
and that will allow us to take a look
at some of the data sets and some of the
example or projects that we will cover
in the program
okay so uh to go there so
if you could please share the link
okay so when you get to this program
uh sorry when you get to this portal
learn omixlogic.com
you can create a free login this login
is going to be
free for anyone you don't have to
participate in the program
in fact if you would like to use this
asynchronously you can
okay when i share my screen let me stop
sharing just real quick
um so when you create your accounts
you will gain access to both the
coursework
and the both the coursework
and the platform
okay so here you can see that you can
create an account
for free those of you that don't have an
account you can do that now
i'm just going to sign in
and once you're in i will show you what
are some of the resources that will be
using
and later on i will pass it on to
somalika to also look
at how to register for the program
itself
okay so please let me know once you're
in
and once you have an account you can
put yes or number one or something like
that in the chat box so that we know to
proceed
okay so i see people signing up right
now
so if you have not signed up yet please
sign up i want to
demonstrate how the program resources
are going to work
okay thank you david
all right thank you dr beshear
okay so hopefully you've created your
account now
you will find that your account comes
with a
personal profile and in this profile the
first thing that you want to do
is you want to finalize your name your
profile picture give it some description
about you
and this is going to become your
personalized center of
your learning experience so here you
will find the courses that you are
taking
your progress if you've completed some
course you will see a certificate
you will also see your certificate
separately here if you would like to
download them
but importantly you're also going to
have these programs here
and so once you join one of the programs
again you will see
what are the specific things that are
associated with each one of our programs
so if you go to the programs tab
here here you will find all of the
upcoming programs that we have
and in this particular programs on
precision medicine
we have included a number of courses and
projects
that are going to be relevant for your
ability to learn
and apply bioinformatics techniques to a
variety of
questions and examples so here you will
find projects like
the cancer genome atlas an example with
liver cancer project
you will see some projects on cobit 19
you will see some technical skills that
are going to be useful
as you learn to integrate visualize and
analyze your data
and you will see a number of
explanations about some
important machine learning techniques
that we will cover in the course as well
so take a look at this and later on
zononica will explain exactly
how this program is organized to
continue
and pass it on the main
component i think that differentiates
this program
from some of the other programs that
you will find online on similar topics
is that this is not just
access to these online resources this is
access to
training material big data processing
which you will typically not find in
anywhere else
and this is going to give you some real
examples
of methods to process your data and so
to briefly introduce this
resource all of you that have an account
you can use the same account to access
a demo pipeline that i will briefly
demonstrate
to show you how easy you can go from
learning about
a specific method of analysis to
actually using that method of analysis
and so to do that i will go under the
transcriptomic
section and i will open a number of demo
projects that we
will use during this program so one of
them is called the cell line project
and so this is a project where they took
a variety of
cancer of breast cancer cell lines and
performed
gene expression analysis so they
generated transcriptomic data
to understand what differentiates
between different types
of breast cancers so here we can
quickly process the same data and as we
go through the analysis
appreciate what are some of the logical
steps that you need to
take to go from raw next generation
sequencing data fast q files
all the way to getting a table of
expression so the main
steps are pre-processing mapping and
then quantification of expression levels
and what i'll do today is i'll build a
very simple pipeline
that in reality if you were to try and
make this pipeline on your own
might take you maybe a few hours a few
days or even a few weeks depending on
your level of expertise but you'll see
how quick and simple this could be right
here
so first of all what we'll do is we'll
clean up those raw reads
and we'll make sure that we remove the
technical adapters
from library preparation we will then
address the
issue of pcr amplification that could
bring in some technical
variation that we don't want to confuse
with biological simple
signal then we will align these reads to
the reference genome using both type 2
and then we will quantify the levels of
expression
to get a table of fpm gene expression
using rsem once we've completed this
pipeline i can click on
end and i will take a look at some of
the output data
so it's a real quick process to go from
having that raw data to then analyzing
that data and you
saw some of the variations into the
pipeline that you can make as you go
through
and then get getting a result so that
you can appreciate the inputs and the
outputs very quickly
once you get those results importantly
we have
all kinds of additional methods to line
this data visualize this data
and even integrate multi-omics data to
quickly understand the relationship
between
gene expression genomic variants
maybe microrna and long non-coding rna
as well as some clinical information